ross stripling the 30 year old
right-hander is 3-0 with a 4-e-r-a
stripping in his fifth season in the big
leagues already fernando eight-game
hitting streak longest by padre this
year on a one-two pitch
he got him swinging second out for that
at-bat before the padres tonight indeed
right-hander garrett richards will go to
the hill he's owen one with a 4.60 era
finally healthy after four seasons
produced just six wins for the
right-hander as bellinger steps in
bellinger full beard at bat parallel
right behind his head
then brings it out for a line drive
short hop by haas to second for one back
to first the boys turn a double play
turner at 250
leading it off in the second
turner lifts a fly ball to left field
that sends pro far back at the wall
oopsing can't get it
justin turner into second with a double
but more importantly his 1000th career
major league hit
and he knows
and now chris taylor coming up
here on a 1-2 from richards he reaches
out flips it down the line that'll drop
in and things sometimes tend to even out
don't they chris taylor with the dunk
shop base hit and the dodgers have the
game's first run
13 for 50 a home run and six runs batted
in for [ __ ] hernandez
hernandez sends this one to left profile
going back it's over his head and off
the bottom of the wall
taylor sprinting around is going to try
and score all the way from first base
throw the play will be
in time they got him hedges applies the
tag
and hedges got some words there for
taylor as in hey man
i ain't blocking the plate but you're
hitting me anyway haas gets me in
between them and austin hedges going to
get a measure of revenge released an
opportunity for one here with the tying
run in scoring position nobody out and
austin coming up d01 tries to bunt again
it's a pretty good one back towards the
mound stripling picks it up throws high
to first bellinger can't handle it and
rounding third heading home is
cronenworth this game is tied 1-1 in the
third base has loaded nobody out with
grisham at the plate he walked his first
time hedges at third profile second to
tease it first
curb is swatted to third turner's got it
and comes home for the force out
one down and machado at the plate
he has nine career grand slams but he
also hit into a double play his first
time
lifts a fly ball headed towards left
center field and deep back goes pollock
and ball he's gone
grand slam for manny machado and the
padres with one swing of the bed take a
5-1 lead machado takes it out of the
yard at dodger stadium that's a grand
slam for manny machado
the padres do take advantage as manny
leaves the yard for the fifth time
on the young season
first and second
one out and bellinger coming up nothing
in two hedges an inside target the pitch
is away and grounded a second
cronenworth flips to tatis for one the
throw to first in time double play start
of the fifth inning ross strippling on
the mound for los angeles number nine
hitter jerks and profar at the plate
it's this one in the air to right field
pretty well mookie betts going back onto
the track at the wall it's gone
turks at profar
another home run for profar and the
padres had on to their lead more home
runs it's six to one number down man
jericho profile chipping in and his
second of the year one away for mandy
runner at second one out in the fifth
now throw to second base and tatis is
picked off
picked off one four
now two gone now a one two cost the
padres a run there's a base hit by manny
into center field that would have scored
fernando tatis instead manny has a
multi-hit ball game and a four-game
hitting streak already the lefty brought
in to get eric hosper who has struck out
and flied to right two gone 6-1 padres
fifth inning first pitch osmer swings
and grounds it to third
picked up by turner easy throw across
the diamond in one pitch kolaric
does away with hospital here's mookie
vance with a chance to get the dodgers
back into the game fastball right down
the middle a mistake and a high fly ball
that is on the track reaching out
grisham makes the one hand grab
bounces off the sign right there beth's
shaking his head like i thought i had
that and now the hedges
it's a roller to the hole in short
taylor over to get it to get the out at
second and the first a double play
now pollock coming up
last time up
he went first ball swinging and lying
down he hit the ball really hard to
right field first pitch right down the
middle put it in play man that's what he
does manny comes way over to his left in
front of junior and makes the grab and a
throw one two three not exactly tiring
here
in the 80 plus pitches for garrett
richards as good as he was against the
dodgers in petco he's better stadium
today he's got manny machado right here
and right now
fly down the right field line betts
is under it to end the ending
tough night for cody two double plays
and a fly out to left
turns on this and grounds into first but
picked on the backhand by hosmer he'll
win the race to the bag for the out as
betts takes third base two down in the
inning mookie bench is at third base and
turner at the dish here's the o2 turner
swings lines it into center grisham
comes in and makes the catch hard hit
barnes comes up trying to build off a
double earlier tonight
two on two out ninth inning and an o2
pitch
from javigara
dribbler through the right side it's a
base hit barnes second of the night
rios goes to third
so it's 6-2
batting for the first time
took over defensively in left field
after will smith back for chuck peterson
in the eighth
and on the first pitch lifts a fly ball
to short left field incoming his pro far
he'll get there makes the catch and the
padres win
so pomerantz on one pitch able to pick
up the save tonight as the padres win
this one six to two
and they take game two of this four game
series they've taken the first two and
manny machado with a big grand slam
final again padres six dodgers two